I've never met a single conservative or
seen in any Republican lawmaker who's
ever proposed to make miscarriages
illegal I've never seen it so please
check in Anna if you have any evidence
at all I know you don't put them on your
videos because he can't be bothered any
proof at all shake and any at all it
doesn't exist it's a lie let me ask what
is the most convincing pro-abortion
pro-choice argument to you and why do
you think it's not used by anyone who's
prominently on air from the left because
you know I've argued this quite a bit if
you've not seen to change my mind
segments but coming across this Young
Turks video today it was one second I
think like philosophy 101 what is this
these are the weakest arguments that you
can watch how to rebut abortion
arguments on YouTube and the first
arguments that show up and they say
we're not gonna spend a lot of time on
this chapter yeah because no one uses
that beyond 12 years old right so only
give you some context here democratic
debates Kamala Harris said that there
weren't laws regulating what men could
do with their bodies the same way that
there were women ben shapiro pointed out
that that was factually inaccurate and
then the young turks about lost their
mind i want to set a context before we
get to the blatant lie here we go
Kamala Harris made a point about how
women's bodies are regulated in a way
that men's bodies don't get regulated I
already said that
and then her comment that that there's
not a single law that tells a man what
to do with his body try virtually every
law that applies to human beings right
I'm not allowed to use my body to smack
my employees I'm not allowed to use my
body to sell drugs there are lots of
different things you're not allowed to
do with your body okay it seems pretty
reasonable something that someone so
when you're just fat check man everyone
just fact check me on this right now we
have a lot of sources yeah I want you to
read all of them because you will notice
in this segment from The Young Turks can
anyone take a guess how many sources
they provide hmm carry the one no it's
yeah it's zero that means you're on Z
yeah it fell somewhere in America from
of nothingness they play 30 seconds of
bench appear this is important because
yeah just a lot on the left they place
thirty seconds of a Ben Shapiro clip out
of context I want you to go watch this
entire video of The Young Turks in
context to make sure that I'm not trying
to pull a fast one on you they play 30
seconds and then a 10 minute video with
no sources at all or scientific
references whatsoever when you're
discussing a biological issue nary an
overlay and this is later in the video
but I thought we had to address this on
the outside as quickly as possible
this is something I don't want to
explain it because then they might
repeat what I said again not an agenda
redundancy this was an argument actually
made on air do you know how many
fertilized eggs how many pregnancies end
in miscarriage right so it's just so do
we criminalize women when that happens
right well some of the laws are written
so poorly that or maybe on purpose that
that that would be the effect of some of
the Republican laws that are being
considered in in some of the red states
yeah where they say well look well I
don't know if it was a miscarriage or an
abortion it's uh your responsibility to
prove that it was a miscarriage and so a
lot of woman who had miscarriages if
those laws were to pass and they were
too whole and of course were to hold
them up yeah we'd have a massive issue
because there's a ton of miscarriages
and they would start locking people up
lock women up for miscarriages now I
want to be really clear about something
here I've always said we don't want to
be in the business of attributing motive
right and you always have to allow for
the positive for it to be the most
likely possibility right if you think
that somebody is lying it is usually
more likely that they are incorrect and
that they're simply ignorant they have a
blind spot yeah okay I usually start off
with that as a premise I want to be
clear here the Young Turks are lying to
their audience this is a logon some they
are being deliberately [ __ ] ana you are
being deliberately dishonest yes with
your audience I do not believe for a
second that you couldn't be bothered to
do any research to support this idea
that Republicans want to outlaw
miscarriages right and a lot of red
states none of the latter is some of
them you know those red I don't know how
to rebut it we'll do our best so I just
decided I couldn't find all of the red
states where that's absolutely right
correct I agree with you cheek fully
employed here's the detail I just said
let me look at the the law that they
found most egregious it was Georgia
Alabama yeah so even then I guess this
is something that's circulated regarding
the Georgia law Snopes has said that
this is not true at all now I don't know
I don't know if there are other states
where miscarriages are illegal I've
never met a single conservative or seen
any Republican lawmaker who's ever
proposed to make miscarriages illegal
I've never seen it so please check and
Ana if you have any evidence at all I
know you don't put them on your videos
because he can't be bothered provide
anything any proof at all shake any it
all it doesn't exist it's a lot all
right look at the next clip you can't
argue that it's for small government you
just can't
so when they life are you saying is I'm
against taxes on my rich benefactors
that's exactly right
right it couldn't be that someone it
couldn't be that someone could argue
from a small government perspective that
murder should be illegal because that's
the one fundamental role of government
right right to ensure that the citizens
are kept safe both from inside an
exterior threats life liberty and the
pursuit of life so what are you small
government when you want to make
miscarriages illegal right only because
of your conservative benefactors hold on
this is something else that really
bothers me this is what you see anytime
you have an opinion whether it's climate
change whether it's abortion whether
it's the the the pay gap anytime you
have an opinion what the left will do is
they'll say oh you must be funded by big
oil oh you must be funded by the Koch
brothers I have I have yet to receive
any Koch brother money I would gladly
take it here's something that I would
also like people to look at because I do
see this from people on the right a
little bit [ __ ] conspiratorial he
minded and I think it's incorrect what
is more likely that ben shapiro has
entirely changed his tune because he has
some ambassadors and he does have some
investors who who have made a lot of
money granted or if you look at ben
shapiro has been expressing the exact
same opinions since i've known him since
he was doing a local show in orlando
florida from his from his dead that i
would appear on almost every single week
and then someone
around who had some money said hey where
can I invest this to to increase
influence to get my to get a message out
there that I agree with yeah that's more
likely you will often hear you say
correlation does not equal causation is
it more likely that ben shapiro who is
now expressing the exact same point of
view that he had six seven eight nine
years ago and you can you can back check
this because he's been writing books
since he was four got a lot of material
in this he had a Gerber spoon in one
hand in a quill in the other listen I
don't of this company what we have a
licensing agreement with the blaze why
because we were successful is it hey how
can we partner up yeah so it's not an
argument but it's also very lazy unless
you can point out someone's point of
view that it has entirely transformed
once benefactors came in now I wouldn't
even say that about the Young Turks
getting twenty million dollars from from
foreign investors who would support a
foreign caliphate because you always
supported a foreign caliphate let's go
to the next argument because I have to
let them say it in their own words so
the sperm has met the egg and now you
have a zygote you say well that's
obviously life if you're in the
anti-choice category anti-abortion etc
well why is that obvious that's also a
potential life scientists like semen is
first as a firm future cannot Sima it's
not viable if you take out the semen by
itself it's not viable if you take out
the egg by itself it's not viable if you
take out the zygote and it's also not
viable first up it's that net semen
sperm is the living cell it would be as
opposed to saying ovaries like vaginal
discharge why would you say semen I
think he means to say sperm and no one
this is again this is not a mainstream
argument from Republicans on the right
and certainly not the one that ben
shapiro made sure that i make sperm is
not a life for the same reason that a
sperm is not a life for the same reason
that ovaries not a life or these skin
cells are not like when we had something
to change my mother wore different let
me tell you exactly why these clones
okay okay humanities philosophy 101 we
get that you had a professor and he gave
you an a on your paper because you asked
a bunch of hypotheticals it's very
simple only when a sperm fertilizes an
egg at the moment of conception right
now
of unique DNA that is not DNA of the
mother of the fodder fodder hello father
it is DNA in entirely unique to that new
being and I say this is someone whose
researched DNA quite at DNA testing and
they have to do sometimes for some of
the the health stuff that I can do the
DNA can tell your eye color your hair
color male pattern baldness proclivity
toward cancer Alzheimer's whether you
have some kind of autoimmune conditions
it's amazing with if you were to take
that D a DNA sample from yourself right
now do you realize it outside of I I
don't know some really extreme mutations
that might occur to environmental
factors you know it'll be the same DNA
as taken from a zygote that's crazy
that's why it's after fertilization its
conception which by the way it's not
it's no longer potential life if you
just don't kill it it is a human being
that's not the same with a sperm by the
way 96% of biologists agree that life
begins after fertilization and these are
people a majority of them identified by
the way as pro-choice or liberal over 85
percent of them and science is not
governed by consensus I know so if you
don't say that 96 percent matters just
read a textbook because that's the
definition is the textbook definition of
life that would take research though by
the way that that's probably the dumbest
argument that I've heard and that's the
first time that I've heard somebody say
that sperm is the same thing the same
thing as a fertilized egg like it is the
most it is the most basic argument and
it's one that when I was preparing to do
the change my minds well as doing debate
prep with reg well no one really brings
it up anymore because it and you know
why because no mainstream conservative
is arguing that point right now I know
you get some people who are against
contraception I understand that that
still is not the main line argument
against abortion no the only consistent
line to draw you can't get into
viability because and that's
geographically dependent it's it's also
dependent as to what era you're born in
because viability is only expanding that
definition of them the more modern
technology becomes even more modern or
technology or here again just like
finding just like earlier when you're
saying that they want to ban they want
to make miscarriages illegal please find
me the legislative body that is trying
to push for abortion legislation that
involves make
masturbating illegal right mm-hmm
no one is saying that your sock drawer
is off Fitz let's go well yours maybe
let's now over the next clip map now
everyone agrees by the way they'll lie
to you and they mislead you all the time
once the bait desirable it is an
independent life form what and all
liberals progressives pro-choice people
agree then once it's an independent life
form it has rights yeah and you can't
have an abortion at that point ok ok ok
that's very clear everyone agrees
ok [ __ ] what's the week ok one degrees
yeah check Anna please this is the call
to you
what's the week 1822 is that Colorado's
28th
is it 32 since all liberals are great
just like apparently Republicans want to
make miscarriage is illegal what's the
week viability is a moving target here's
something else try to find any
progressive right now running for the
Democratic candidates I know that Bernie
Elizabeth Warren would not answer they
did not think that abortion legislation
should be dependent on viability
they said up until birth yeah they
wouldn't put any limitations on it so
I've seen that the only one who I did
see put limitations on any restrictions
on abortion was Tulsi Gabbard by the way
restrictions after 28 weeks that's seven
months far after the point of viability
and guess what no Jordan feather dur as
a Russian asset this extreme we all
agree that once the baby is viable that
is right able to have an abortion all
Democrats agree and one Democrat says
okay so how about like long after the
viability cut off like seven months is
that okay just celebrated legalizing
abortion up until birth Rhode Island
became the eighth state was the eighth
with it round eight number eight this is
this is absolutely insane to me they
said we all agree this is something that
is so intellectually lazy and I want to
know you out there people who are
pro-life when you argue this issue what
arguments you come you find yourself at
an impasse most consistently okay now I
would say this we've often seen people
try to say well viability is subjective
or as
that's dependent on the mother and there
are arguments to be had there because I
don't think that they really hold up the
only consistent line that you can draw
is the scientific - biologically
establish line of conception replicas on
you just say well everyone agrees and
the left we all agree the left it's not
gay give me a week because guess what
leftist states can't even agree if you
go from Colorado to promote where you
can report it all the way up to eight
months and some people they don't agree
so you tell me since it's so clear
because I just want to get a handle on
where does it you're coming from and I
certainly can't do with the National DNC
candidates by the way people who tend to
be most affected by miscarriages people
who tend to feel it more deeply would be
people who believe that's an actual life
yeah so as someone who's had a deeply
personal experience with whatever you
want to guess friends or family with
miscarriages I know how difficult that
can be for the woman yes and by the way
that's consistent with a conservative a
right-leaning worldview because we do
believe that that is a life lost yeah so
let's not act as though the right are
the the right are the ones who want to
punish women because of miscarriages and
this is the thing this is so lazy let's
let's recap it the right wants to ban
all miscarriages and no source
whatsoever right none been Shapiro's
arguments which by the way do not
consist of banning miscarriages I wanna
make sure in case I haven't been clear
he only makes these arguments because of
Republican benefactors and then everyone
agrees on the point of viability for
which they provide no timeline
whatsoever the only reason that people
like The Young Turks or Seth Meyers or
Trevor Noah
or NBC ABC CBS CNN the only reason they
can be this intellectually disingenuous
and lace is because there's been no
accountability for years no one would
say when Brian Williams would just make
[ __ ] up would say huh that's all that's
required tell me then what is the number
well it's something or other benefactors
no no no one no one has called him on it
even ATO terrified we would be to go out
with arguments this paper-thin we would
never do it if I were going out to do a
change my mind or do one of the baits
that we have with plenty of left us
you've come on the show and all I had
for the pro-life position is well sperm
is a life I would be I would be soiling
myself we wouldn't even do it on the
show yes coming on the show without
somebody pushing back we wouldn't do no
sure
like this is gonna get blown up
someone's gonna do a rebuttal and
they're going to be correct very clear
to me it is increasingly clear that
people like Ana and [ __ ] have never
actually debated the the topic of
abortion as seen by the fact that they
present the most rudimentary arguments
that have been thrown out completely and
could be done completely by a high
school debate team captain you only have
to be captain could be third string
whose parents made him join the debate
team you'll say listen I'm pro-choice
but I don't even believe the whole sperm
stuff do you guys have a source for that
look at your factors I literally just
had this is a public school and I think
this is really important people who are
out there when you were crafting your
arguments to not sound like that you
know what let's make this a PSA a PSA to
not sound like shank or an ax
okay students and when we do when we do
jujitsu we have a team and I've helped
coached you Jitsu before my mind is
better than my body at this point I we
always have a policy we only teach
techniques that actually work against
world-class black belt yeah you'll have
some things that you learn early on and
then you try it you go well that didn't
really work because they just sort of
teach you some basic concepts or
fundamentals but it's not the most
effective technique if it works on
somebody who knows what they're doing
then that's something that you can trust
but you can only know that if you
actually attempt to use that technique
on someone who knows what they're doing
the same can be said for an argument
you only know if it holds water if you
regularly engage in these kinds of
discussions with people who might
challenge you on them they don't do that
that's how you end up with this carriage
is what upload this I feel good about
this if you like this video click one of
these other videos playing in a box up
there and hit subscribe or the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed so you can find out about our
new non-controversial videos which don't
ruffle any feathers and of course are
not a violation of YouTube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except oh I
don't know if we are but it's our
channel not sure how that works